but yeah you're pretty locked in with
your with what you got as a man i think
gravity is taking not just my balls but
it's going down so it tends it's just
it's hanging low and when it's hot yeah
and and it's late it's a lazy day it's
it's a little astonishing i gotta i
gotta like you're like you're resting
your resting rate is insane i know my
girl was like look at your dick yeah i
was like well just a heavy like it's a
heavy leg i hate that i saw it and you
you'll never see mine so stop asking
well because you feel a little insecure
around my dong and i want you to know
that
you're young and tight and don't be
upset about it young and tight i'll take
it you're going to tell me my excuse
being up well not obsessed my excuse is
not like i don't care if i see your dick
or not because i grew up in locker rooms
your excuse yeah well i said that's true
i send you videos periodically so you
can keep you honest i enjoy it no no no
no no no so a lot of times if i if i
have my if my dong's out and my girl's
taking me a video and i don't know yeah
i'm naked i'm doing a dance i'll send it
to brennan to keep monitoring and then
why are you always dancing and then all
i reply back is tweeting this
[Laughter]
he goes no please god no he's got no i
have to please god
why do you date every time let's get off
his dick real quick
do you have that i think finally kid
posted the [ __ ] video crystalia oh
that [ __ ] was funny so [ __ ] funny so
funny
do you know brian callahan
hey you should talk to brendan young
funny kid he goes
[Laughter]
he's so funny man
is this so [ __ ] funny what's this
you know who my one one of my favorite
comedians are that i that i wish was uh
was more um was more well known and i
said who he said brian callahan
and i said huh
he said brian callahan and i said do you
mean brian callan and he said yup
and i said oh yeah yeah sure yeah he's
great and he said yeah do you know him
and i said
uh
yeah yeah i know him very very well he
said really i said yep he said well you
know what you should do do you know who
brendan schaub is and i said
yeah
you should go on fighter and the kid
and i was like
hey man
are you [ __ ] mental
how do you know
who they are
know who i
oh yeah he said you should ask brendan
for tickets to the next uf's
me and myself
how the [ __ ]
do you know
who brian calvin is and you don't know
who i am dude delia
wake up call wake up
straight up [ __ ]
straight up [ __ ] what are you what
was it going to say god damn it
i don't know
we're moving down
[Laughter]
yeah yeah okay oh okay i was like
thought he was [ __ ] with me dude
fighter and dude fighter
who fighter in the kid dude i was guest
of the year [ __ ] twice in a row the
first time it was fixed
they're sad
so sad
he is one of the greats the good one of
the great i [ __ ] love that dude
he's so funny
he says you know i'd love it i'd love to
get him in here when he's here me
[ __ ] too
he's so [ __ ] funny he's [ __ ]
hilarious
brian callahan
goddammit that was the first dude i
meant in comedy ever chris in arizona or
in arizona when i the when i knew he was
going to be something was when he
opened for me and dove david off at the
comedy store in la jolla yep and he goes
how long ago was that i don't know
literally 20 years ago well my kids my
kid was i think
literally that kid was probably three so
at least 10 years ago but it has to be
12 years ago yeah 13 years ago
and he it's [ __ ] weird how time flies
and he
he goes you know when a deer gets shot
and you don't kill it
and he he was lean he had this lunge
i've never seen a lunge like this i go
well he's made of rubber and he was like
and he turned like that and the [ __ ]
place went nuts and and i was like all
right that's difficult to follow because
i'm a physical media that guy's made a
rubber he's plasticine he's the most
physical he's stretch armstrong
oh and by the way
the other thing i noticed was when i got
on stage i noticed
the women had a palpable disappointment
in their
demeanor they were just like where's our
boyfriend we missed our boyfriend who's
this [ __ ] guy old guy
who's who i wasn't even that old who's i
was pretty cute 13 years ago chris
emceed and opened and then dove then you
it was that no it was chris then me and
then dove yeah
you and dove look like brothers like you
know
you know
yeah i'm a little better compared to
chris yeah well chris i mean yeah yeah
he did that bit on his comedy central
presents that 30-minute special yeah
he's i always say this chris
i say it's
to anybody funniest person i know yeah
that's that's fair
always hands down
and in person always only thinking about
that so she makes me laugh so
our good friend frank willow likes to
box in different cities and chris was
like well i don't like when manly men do
manly things
you act don't be boxing yeah hey do you
guys know of any place like uh in this
city right when he gets up he's going to
say you know i can
find a gym and move my hands about yeah
do you know any area any like gym
a musty
sort of poorly lit space i can walk run
around jump around and move my hands
really quickly around and i was like and
i was like that's basically funny
when he came on here and he's just on
one and you he would be telling the
story to interrupt and go
talking bro he embarrassed me i was in i
was at the montreal comedy
i was at the
comedy festival and i'm with a bunch of
people and he sees my bag
and i was secretly going to box because
when i was really into boxing i would go
to i go to try to find a coach to teach
me and you remember you were like what
are you doing so
he goes
he sees my stuff and he goes let's go to
this thing and i go i can't he goes
where you go
get mad and there are all these other
comics around i go ah and he goes open
your back right now
and he sees i had some boxing gear he
saw like my gloves or something and he
goes and he's loud you're not going
boxing because you're an actor and
you're sold
oh god
he's so [ __ ] so funny the best oh
he's starting up some at the laugh
factory maybe
he's done like jamming advantage yeah
he'll get out of here he'll go on the
road and he'll sell out
everywhere he'll be fine yeah he's gonna
be fine totally would
what you guys i'm sure he's waiting for
the uh cove he's like uh
he comes to cover he's all scared and
[ __ ] yeah they're growing with his house
he was six feet apart that annoys me i'm
like what are you we're friends
noises what do you do
i'll kiss you yeah you stop that right
now yeah everybody here's a question
when your girl's sick
when your girl's got a cold nothing more
annoying do you stay away do you kiss do
you i don't give a [ __ ]
[Music]
no if she wants to make out though and
she's got a bad cold well she's not
going to make out and she has a bad tool
who's trying to make out and she's going
to go back she goes to kiss you no no
she's not okay yeah that's my girl i
mean i i tend to go like he's like oh
yeah just kidding
well who's like hey babe i have a cold
yeah yeah that'd be weird i've done that
though
i've been like i'm immune system you
told me you told me you was [ __ ] on
covet
oh yeah i do it all yeah you don't get
it you're insane kova didn't stop me but
his girl had it too though i felt like
oh you guys said at the same time
oh easy though over there was coffee
mcgees i think i couldn't get out of
there fast enough oh wow they could it
hit me
you had a bad cough her lungs her lungs
are never the same her lungs are just
now getting better i'm not really yeah
dude she was a long hauler
damn hey man hold on nothing drives me
more nuts
she you know she's she had about a year
and she's still suffering
no she's not hello hey but also
hey michael yo no she's not
dude some people are long-haul
hey you're big
yeah and then i'm sure maybe she got a
cold she's like that cove it's still
here
it's cold
my lungs got stronger i feel like i took
that steroid and you've just never been
strong wait you took a steroid
like the um
inhaler i i got good [ __ ] wind yeah
don't get in a run race with me because
i'm going to keep up with you and i'm
staying and i'm 54. i know where i went
last night with that uh
it's it felt like the first time in l.a
where it's normal because they have a i
don't know it's always been that way but
it's it's a restaurant complete outside
it's on top of the building catch
oh they can remove the so you're outside
so like when i was like oh [ __ ] i forgot
a mask and i was like you're good man
and like every nobody was in masculine
really
the best food i've ever had really and
it's just felt everything felt normal
where is this catch is off beverly hills
mm-hmm
right
like west hollywood really yeah you take
sunset down yeah
good food great [ __ ] what'd you get
uh i had the fillet best best steak f in
l.a really on [ __ ] you've never been
here brian you're a foodie guy no unreal
i went there i went there for lunch when
they first opened years ago with uh todd
uh feldman there's a new
uh steak place we need to but but that
was that place is the first place i felt
normal in l.a is that right the first
time i ever felt normal so matu if
you're a single man go there
would you would you call it there's some
house bar all right i'll go to catch not
not that i'm single but it's not easy to
get in like you only be single hard to
get into yeah is it hard yeah
that's where connor and khabib were at
and they didn't know they were both
going they almost spot each other oh no
that's the restaurant yeah is that right
yeah
phenomenal food ridiculous food they
have good sushi great steak great drinks
wow atmosphere is great and you're and
you're outside like like you're kind of
it but it's it's you are and you aren't
it's an atrium then wait there's a
picture to the right
of the outside
that's nice i like that very much yeah
ooh it's [ __ ] great oh that looks
cool
can that compare to that salt bay
[ __ ] place i went to that's where
loud loud and the most expensive food
you've ever had the place was trash chin
look up matu
sugar fish have opened a steak house
it's a japanese and it's supposed to be
ridiculous fire i guess where's it oh
you haven't been i think it's in malibu
i think it's in uh i think it's near
nobu i may be wrong matu
matu
yeah
and yeah oh there it is
oh look at those ratings
yeah sometimes that stuff can get super
spartan and i think i'd rather go to
catch you know what i mean
because that looks like the catch looks
like it has more what was that squid up
top there
what is it might just be oh yeah i was
like this mushroom yeah
is this one place you gotta cook your
own food
i'll stay home
where
yeah you know i'll stay home i agree i
don't think i'm not that i don't know
that's my problem with korean barbecue
dude i'll [ __ ] grill at home yeah uh
it's super fresh though it's right there
every meal i've ever had
yeah
it makes no sense when i have to cook
the [ __ ] meat and i'm stressed out
about it and someone's there like trying
to talk and flip the meat well you know
what bothers me it's apparently now it's
acceptable to charge
i was at wally's place i go to all time
and i said i'll have the rib eye or
maybe i'll go with the aged 45-day age
strip
oh that's 175
and i go
too much does it come with a bag of
diamonds what huh does it pay half my
mortgage what the [ __ ] are you talking
about 45 days
yeah
yeah it's it's it's 19 ounces or
something or get the [ __ ] i mean 19
ounce steak what do you think 175
dollars yeah
that's fine you're saying that's normal
too much yeah i know i mean 19 ounce
[ __ ] steak that's not that much
because it was like this it was like it
was wagyu or something i'll go to whole
foods right now get a grass-fed steak
for 25 dollars you know what the
restaurant owners say why go to whole
foods
you think they give you fun
i put my foot down steakhouses in
general are a complete nightmare because
hold on for [ __ ]
uh asparagus it's 27 dollars but it's
good asparagus i've never had bad
experience it's the same everywhere i go
or like mashed potatoes 20 25
it's weird bothers me
brussels sprouts are pretty expensive
too but yeah yeah
and all that yeah
like catch it it looks like it's a
pickup joint looks like just beautiful
people everywhere yeah that's an
experience you know you're going to
spend money that was worth it that salt
baby not crazy pricey it was pretty
pricey pretty pricey
not compared to salt based salte has a
1800 steak on the menu for what yeah
it's like lace with gold i'm like why
the [ __ ] would i want that myself oh
yeah i saw that that's weird that kind
of stuff annoys me yeah it's very
strange yeah catch
my favorite restaurant nelly
that's [ __ ] great i i will say this
the best steak is uh at a place called
republic
that's the best part is that out here
school has something to say too though
it's got something to say wait did you
just give a steakhouse in all the world
i'm sorry did you just give a steakhouse
recommendation in all the world and say
it's the best well republic uh they hang
their own stakes it's where charlie
chaplin's old i think did you and i go
charlie chaplin's old offices right on
the break oh it's in california yeah
okay and i i got that as i think i got
that oh you and i went there yeah it's a
great place it's good it's good i've
been there a long time god it's good
i miss that place
yeah
hard to get a table but you walk in and
it's just can't say that i've been so
good no it's charlie chap oh it's uh
it's below his little department yeah
man so well his old offices it's
beautiful beautiful old building man
his house is off the alabama canyon
look at that though look at this was
that yourself you're in a courtyard
eating it's beautiful
oh that's nice
oh dude that little croissant yeah the
food the butter they had this normandy
butter it sounds weird but they have
bread and butter that's
it's this it's good bread though
yeah they bake who the [ __ ] makes bread
what fire have uh oh i think vicente
lucas thomas i was gonna say tom no well
he's a comic
so but the fighter i was talking about
is vicente luke he makes bread he makes
his own sourdough bread and he says he
can eat it the week before the fight and
doesn't gain weight because like
you're saying sourdough yeah he's like
it's actually pretty good for you yes oh
cause it's good
that's what you're saying
you're saying like the gluten stuff it's
different than other breads you know
goddamn spelt can be that way spelt with
buttermilk and like flax seeds you can
live on that [ __ ] that's nice you can't
find his bread
that's him here he's a monster yeah
great [ __ ] dude
really really good dude rough dude dude
when we flew him out here because you
know
usually it happens because i'll text
guys because i know him
and then showtimer malcolm media booked
their flights i thought for some reason
he was in new jersey because he was born
there and then moved to brazil when he's
like seven but i still thought he
trained in new jersey
and i go how's the flight he's like you
know a little long i'm like yeah new
jersey's a [ __ ] beast amazing
no i came from brazil i mean
you flew from brazil just through the
food truck he's like yeah oh no holy
[ __ ]
i like the show but wow i wouldn't fly
to brazil to do the tonight show what's
he find out what way
monster yeah yeah she should get a big
big fight next what's his ranking
four
monster so he'll be right there yeah
again this reads for brian two f3 men
will experience some form of hair loss
by time they're 35 more than 50 dudes in
the us suffer from male pattern baldness
my friends at keeps offer simple
stress-free way to keep your hair
all you got to do man
it's low-cost treatment start just 10
per month keeps offers generic versions
discreet little package shows up proven
results keeps has more than five star
reviews than any of its competitors
prevention is key that's what brian
didn't do treatments can take four to
six months to see results so act right
now if you're ready take action prevent
hair loss go to keps.com
fighter to receive your first month of
treatment free
that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash fighter to get
your first month free keeps.com fighter
boy remember those days then you'd
overdraft they charge you a hefty fee on
top of it it's a good way to ruin your
day well thanks to my friend at chime
chime dot com slash fighter we got you
covered all right when you're online
checking account balance is running
super low the last thing you need is a
33 overdraft fee ain't nobody got time
for that overdraft fees i've gotten way
out of hand in 2019 traditional banks
took 11 billion dollars in overdraft
fees goddamn 11 billion dollars uh chime
does things different now you deserve to
have financial peace of mind join the
millions of americans already loving
chime sign up takes only two minutes
doesn't affect credit score get started
today at chime dot com slash fighter
chime dot com slash fighter
here we go
banking services provide buy and debit
card issued by bank corp bank or stride
bank n a members fdic
spot meals will require supply overdraft
only applies to debit card prices and
cash withdrawals limits start at 20
bucks maybe increase up to 200 bucks by
chime chime member overdraft fees
savings based on eligible members use of
spot me verse 33 average overdraft fee
over fee database on bank rate checking
account survey and crl june 2020
overdraft fees report
it's chime baby chime dot com fighter
uh can i get your take since we're on it
are you putting your money on wilder or
i don't know i go back and forth i have
this weird thing i don't know what it is
that wilder i said this last time that
wilder might clip them but i don't know
while there's new he's working his jab a
lot apparently and there's not enough
hours in the day to get a jab to beat
tyson fury what does he look good though
wilder looks wilder he missed so stupid
muscular like he just looks like he's
put on
crazy muscle
shape too which is trouble
but wilder is the best
yeah
another problem is last time they fought
he got like he didn't get beat he just
got dismantled yeah
it's like when florida atlantic plays
alabama they lose 70 to zero like dude
they're that one there you go look at
this look at him look look at that like
he's got a towel how tall is he where's
he got his dick root in our face
just why ever wear clothes i wouldn't i
would never wear clothes i would never
wear clothes he's such a good dude i
think it's i think it'd be good for
boxing if you won because then you get a
fourth fight
and then the loser and we'll see what
contractually if andy joshua still wants
to do it you get anthony joshua fights
the loser you tell me you won't watch
let's say dante water loses and vegas is
right you went watch deontay wilder and
[ __ ] anthony joshua and then the
winner that gets to
[ __ ] go against fury again all so the
three of them are all going to make so
much money do the three were making
money because yeah joshua lost the guy
who beat him usyk
we don't care all we care about is those
three
when they win or lose all we care about
those three but but don't you feel like
usyk is in that mix isn't he gonna well
it's gonna be mandatory you're gonna
have because he took all the belts i
know so you're gonna make it mandatory
but that's not the money five well i
don't i think he's too small to beat
wilder i mean fury i mean and i think
that he stands uh
ustic is a better boxer technically he's
better than all of them
right even better than fury yeah yeah
yeah just phenomenal he's fundamental
but he's much he's smaller but he is 220
that's big enough
but he's just not going to does not guys
win rounds and heavyweights lose rounds
like usyk with his cardio he can you
know heavyweights will feel each other
out it really any bucks or will you feel
each other out for six rounds yup that's
a problem with boxing dude don't do 12
rounds so they feel because it you know
it's a science so they feel each other
out for you know four to five rounds and
then the fight starts happening in the
sixth round start figuring each other
out don't have to do that against these
big boys he can win those first six
rounds yeah he he goes to work
yeah wow he's not trying he knows he's
going to the distance he's trying to
knock these guys out so he's just
getting so he's going to get those
points yeah
it's trouble and he's southpaw paying
the ass but
but wilder he's never been hit like you
got like wilder so if that lands i was
thinking about that because he does
stand with his hands up he stands in
your grill i know his heads are moving
but the joshua can hit too though yeah
joshua but while that didn't seem to i
mean joshua didn't seem to unload
to me joshua didn't he doesn't seem to
want it i think he's rich and happy and
he's good he didn't but it also if
you're joshua think about it
the fight between him and fear was
supposed to happen and then wilder comes
in and forces a trilogy fight for
literally went to court and forced it so
if you're joshua and you get ready for
tyson fury and then that's the biggest
fight in english history really ever
ever history ever you know what i'm
saying like the biggest superstar ever
so big so
then that gets taken from you and then
as good as usyk is it's not like a main
fight so i think
he was just like coasting it in and
unfortunately
unless you're a boxing fan nobody even
knows who is like if you're a boxer you
know who he is of course he's a [ __ ]
mom
but if you're a box fan too you're like
ooh that's trouble for joshua
the guy's a [ __ ] savage i don't know
why he's i guess his did his camp have
to take those two yeah it's mandatory
yeah when you own when you have those
belts it's mandatory my thing about
joshua is he seemed just fine losing he
didn't seem
upset about it he seemed
and again i think you're right i think
maybe sometimes people have the person
who can deal with being a superstar and
super rich is canelo the guy who might
not be able to is with so many other
options is joshua he's got he's just a
superstar he's been doing for a while
and remember when he you gotta remember
when he does wembley stadium out there
you talking about what hundred ten
thousand tickets it's a lot of pressure
he also lost to a really good guy by the
way who took his life but then remember
he also lost the ruiz
another fight that was flying under the
radar he said god i guess i'll fight
this fat mexican and then lost yep
i would was he upset about that if i was
he redeemed himself and beat the [ __ ]
out of him yeah
he's just so big and strong you just
think just just use your size and power
through that and just punch the [ __ ] you
know watch on saturday are you yeah
you're on the road this weekend i'm
gonna be in uh columbus i'm in ohio
columbus funny bone come see me friday
saturday it's so nice when uh the the
like i know i have time yeah before the
main event you know i can watch him like
oh thank god but how many times have i
been watching i'll tell chappelle to go
a little longer
that's in the third round just
you got another hot tub yeah i don't
want to try to do it
i'm like i don't want it to stand up i
got to go and miss this fight yeah and
then when i do the meet and greet people
ruin it for me dude what happened with
wild or fear i'm like i didn't i had to
come out here during the second round
please tell me what happened
fury got knocked out and that's how i
find out i'm like don't tell me don't
tell me you want to know well that
doesn't work the robbie lawler don't
tell me yeah because they go on their
phones like right after the show is over
and then they know right away yeah i so
this is this this saturday wow
i'm so excited it's gonna be amazing
what time first big fight and i mean no
standard [ __ ] dude probably nine they'll
probably walk around nine that's the
interesting thing about boxing is if
you know in ufc if the first on the main
card if the first four fights are
knockouts in 10 seconds it doesn't
matter that main event is going that's
right in boxing no dude like canelo
he'll make [ __ ] wait two hours like
you didn't give a [ __ ] no like this one
even if a fight like is a quick fight
they have to fill time yeah you know
boxing like played by pioneers is a
beast because those fights do go quick
they have to fill time yeah because
they're like no kid canelo or floyd
mayweather they they they walk at nine
like they're warming up good luck go
tell them to come out here get them
they walk at night no matter what ufc's
decide oh yeah that's why like when i
was fighting the fc like you'd look at
the three fights before you and if it
was like lighter weights like right have
some time if it was like knockouts like
ah [ __ ] i'd be ready to go man oh did
you ever see anybody in the ufc when
they're before they run a fight was that
were there any locker rooms that were
just completely relaxed and
like you know not like logan paul
you know you're about to fight right you
didn't give a [ __ ] that's that's that's
like that's a gallows mood there like
when you're in when right before you're
gonna fight that [ __ ] is tense yeah it's
like uh it's like uh gladiator remember
they're all waiting that guy pisses his
pants because they're trained together
yeah that's what it's like you're like
stare at each other like all right see
man you're about to fight that person
you're like well going out there
all right fellas
it's like see on the other side see on
the other side fellaini
and then you're so jealous of the person
that went out before you and won and
came back in like oh you're so lucky god
i'm so
jealous i don't know that [ __ ] is just
i wonder i would imagine
well i feel like fury's not like that
he's nervous for sure like what oh he's
also but he's been doing it for so
that's that's my issue picking wilder
but listen i'm a betting man i like
money so the bet is wilder under 12
rounds via knockout to make money you
parliament that's the most that's how
you make money because you better feel
you're not making money so if you want
to make money bet on wilder but it's
like there's not enough days in the week
there's nothing to change your style to
change to use that jab catch up to fury
he's been boxing since he's
four-year-olds in diapers he's got he's
a gypsy yeah he's named after mike tyson
yeah yeah so it's just he speaks that
language and it's like if you were
fluent in spanish and then you know
we're going to debate each other like
but it's in spanish brandon you have six
months like i kind of know spanish oh
yeah so it's like let me let me hire
like it doesn't matter well he has to
know that that brings your weekend
glasses that's gonna try to do exactly
what it did in the second fight which is
get him on his back foot and just
smother him maybe he doesn't have to do
that he doesn't have to do that yeah
he can do it all right yeah that's
although
that's what louder is expecting them
yeah fury's gonna mess with him for a
little bit and then apply the pressure
because he knows how dangerous deonte is
so many things such a good fight so i
can't it's exciting boxing is so
exciting right now when it's high level
there's nothing better when it's people
you don't know there's nothing worse
yeah that i just like mma good i mean
mma is like pizza cold hot i'll [ __ ]
i mean people get [ __ ] up all the time
yeah even if guy has real shitty skill
it's still fun to watch
boxing though cause those guys they
don't have like four fights on tv if
they're not on tv and you don't know who
they are even though they're so
technical might have won a [ __ ] gold
medal in the olympics you're like all
right it's just it's like golf i know
there are some fights that really look
like kobe covington and goosebumps
they really dislike each other was that
november like yeah november uh six six
yeah if you're in town because doing a
uh fight campaign for it yeah i think
i'm in [ __ ] cancel it doesn't matter
off the hook comedy or i'm just oh
cancel oh this is where i am november
6th i don't [ __ ] know
god damn it i mean
i think camaro
by the way
what'd you say tomorrow mobster i think
camaro is a [ __ ] beast well tell me
the last uh fight kobe was in b huh
wouldn't you tell me the last fight
colby was in uh
was it kamar hussman yeah it was camaros
yeah and he lost and who's gotten better
since they last fought tomorrow we have
no idea what kobe and there's only one
way to get better is by fighting like
driving you're [ __ ] you're talking
about
training time but i thought the
classified was woodland talking about
practice you're talking about practice
click on kick click on it now kobe for
me
a couple of things
look at you chappelle all right
chappelle whoo
i was like i said something so that was
that was september 2020. now go to
camaro you can click on them right there
chin you just going right there
you're so good
um
and i saw him when i was in denver
because he's working with trevor whitman
you're like holy [ __ ] yeah yeah and the
guy can box he's not so so large he's
just i can't believe he's not large i
couldn't believe how small he was really
yes
well yeah his legs are like this super
little i was
i don't know if his thighs are that
skinny are they he's he's just to me
he's not a big guy for 170. he's not a
big guy i think he's huge for once
you've seen darren tale or even colby's
like thicker
do you taller guy no no no come on he's
got that uh his mentality is just like
second to none though chandler champion
i'm gonna give you five seconds you
gotta chandler chandler gaijin who you
putting your money on
i don't know chandler's so explosive but
gaechi's it's going to be interesting
keith's a monster what about roseway lee
i saw um i saw uh geichi in denver too
sparring with camaro and these other
guys oh really how you doing manuals
well you know about to get punched in
the face
all right
okay she's a killer you've known him a
long time long time now we got called
sean strickland that's a good fight he's
from arizona right i hope luke uses his
grappling me too he's such a monster
grappler i know such a monster i want
frankie edgar to stop no cheeto you want
to stop cheeto i want i will slap you i
want frank's favorite stuff oh he's a
hall of famer who's amazing i don't want
him to take damage depends on him
depends how this goes huh if that's
gonna be a good fight i don't think
cheeto like ko's them it's gonna be a
great fight but but if he if he yeah if
let's see how he does with this one if
it doesn't go well then yeah maybe
time's done bring up frankie's record
we had that horrible knocked out by
[ __ ] uh by cody uh yeah by santa
hagan yeah now san hagen's fighting
peter yawn and
it's gonna be tough tough for corey it's
been a tough outing for him yeah that
brian ortega was really bad that was the
knee and then ended with the punch yeah
i didn't like that you beat the brakes
off yara rodriguez that was a hot second
ago kept swanson older in the tooth max
hallway's tough korean zombie chins boy
pedro munoz split decision pedro's no
punk yeah but then that corey sanhagan
flying knee was
he's he's a complete killer i i do think
that there's something about fighting
that when you get to a certain age
you lose if you lose a split second your
hands here not here
it can make all the difference
that's why you got a football really you
got to really think about when you when
the object is to shut you off you got to
think about stopping when that matters i
don't know knowing when to stop why did
he so but to remember we were talking
about brian ortega and he said pray for
me i saw that thing was going to the
hospital what was that about i don't
know
he's pretty beat up yeah
yeah yeah yeah that card is stacked yeah
well fight campaign for what we have one
october 30th
for the next big ufc we have one
november 6th and then one for the big
ufc in december 2. it's fighting october
30th
that's ufc
268 i think 267.
yeah i try that
that's good oh they just announced
francis and cyril gone you'll see 270.
oh boy that's going to be yeah october
30 all my money on serial ground but
that's going to be exciting this fight's
these this card is fun man yeah john
glover glover peter young my boy cory
santa hagan yeah makachev dan hooker i
think hooker gets it done to be honest
you do yep that's interesting yep
are you serious yeah he's a monster so i
got i got i got in that john blockovich
peter yan makovich i think those that
that's
what i'll bet you two thousand dollars
of course again beats peter young oh
really yep two thousand yep give me oh
wow
with the quickness done
two thousand dollars yep corey santana
beats peter young yeah you're out of
your mind okay all right i can't wait
peter young is good you guys got two
bets now and all due respect to corey
sanhedrin there's a killer mm-hmm very
interesting
what do you know do you know something
about peter young being injured because
he's not injured no he's not injured
he's a monster yeah it's just you look
at the styles and it's all about styles
there can be a worse matchup for peter
young i think al jermain sterling and tj
is a rough matchup for for corey
sandhagen it's just worked out that he
got to leapfrog them because everyone's
injured and now you have to fight peter
young
peter young's gonna i think is going to
be the long time champion i don't think
anybody beats peter young
i think he's is striking and everything
is just too high too advanced sure just
better yep better yep yep dan hooker how
does dan hooker deal with islam jeff
khabib 2.0
no you're not buying the hype uh he just
has a way to go i think he'll show up
better in this one because not he's not
the main event he's still not ready for
main events yet right but also dan hook
is just a seasoned vet has a lot of ways
to stop him
[ __ ] beast dude killer he's long he's
rangy yep he's been in there with the
best i do
think but he gets put on his back right
i mean what happens then i don't know
how you deal with we'll see you know
what i'm saying
i wouldn't bet on that one but yeah
everybody's on dagestan's nuts but i
mean these are the guys that really
stand out like someone like islam
jefferson no there's a million of them
no there are a lot of great guys but i'm
saying that kind of how do you deal with
a chain wrestling i don't know what dan
hook is going to do
what's the one in december
december is the uh a big boy too oh ufc
is bringing the heat is december ufc 270
is that francis and uh sierra gunn
i think they're 20 20 22. that's january
20th i got serial gun in that fight too
how about you yeah
yeah uh i don't know yet tough
which which one is that in december 269
probably
yeah just 269 december 11th and what's
on yeah let's see that card
man nunez you have moreno and figarito
rematch and the announcements here uh
charles oh dustin poirier is the big one
who's he fighting charles oliveira title
[ __ ] yeah wow and then your boy cody
robert too yep cody versus uh cara
france you got donna cruz on there sean
o'malley's on there didn't cody lose his
last fight i think he got yeah
that was a tough fight for him
it was tough
yeah but now he's at 125.
yeah rob fonte killer
and tj's got knee surgery i guess he had
to he
yeah he was he postponed that because he
had
he was a candidate what surgery anyway
on his knee before this oh he's right
head surgery yeah
but you're not gonna jump in the top
shot after major knee surgery yeah
because what he fought he had to have
his acl reconstruct he's on fight
companion what [ __ ] two months ago
yeah he had surgery directly after that
he had to have his acl acl yeah that's
bad
no oh no he didn't tear his acl he did
not no he tore everything but the acl oh
wow yeah that's why he's fortunate
that's why he's got to be back in train
by december oh wow yeah acl's the worst
yeah yeah i mean they're better at now
like
remember when like adrian peterson uh
tours acl
and it used to be just career suicide
for nfl running backs now it's not that
big of a deal they bounced back from it
wow i think saquon barkley tore his too
yeah he did
he's doing decent yeah jesus christ
fight companion monster
yeah
he posted a video of the surgery after
it look what he did yeah on his
instagram
god he's such a badass
he still won that fight even though he
[ __ ] blew his leg at knee out in the
first round can i see
her dean defense call not stop made a
minute since by ortega was he was tired
okay he wasn't answering questions wrong
that was a weird one too
because he answered the question wrong
ask him again they got it right so let
him go
yeah
um
what one homeboy died in bare knuckles
you see that yeah that's probably
occurring just recently i wonder how
that's gonna yeah yeah oh [ __ ] he got
knocked out never came to you from it
it's like a month later almost and then
he passed away
holy [ __ ] the black guy for bare knuckle
no pun intended
disturbed by regulation of bare knuckle
boxing death that's the guy the hair guy
yeah he died he died yeah dale ugh bare
knuckle boxing has been getting popular
across parts of the united states
um right here disturbingly disturbing
despite recommending some some
jurisdiction regulating these events are
still not following the minimum medical
guidelines set forth by association
boxing commission
uh more concern is the fact that
maintenance do not require any image
studies of ct or mri scan yeah that's
not good terrible especially for a bare
knuckle yeah
it's just tough
do you remember i remember you guys were
talking or was it just you brandon about
you and joe rogan were discussing how
what's safer and what's not safe for
bare knuckle and joe saying rogan and
eddie for the longest run we're saying
he's bringing
but one thing they do is they if they
don't wrap their wrists you know if they
wrap their wrists there's so much more
you know sturdiness there i just think
you'd also get cut more with with just
your knuckles part of that of course
everyone gets slashed though yeah but
that's what they're saying but if they
didn't wrap their wrists i think it'd be
probably safe right because you can't
punch as hard
but then guys are gonna break through
break their hands for sure and i can get
very good fights yeah
yeah there's a reason there's a reason
that things evolve to gloves you have to
look at boxing boxing started bare
knuckle boxing now has gloves there's a
reason for it it makes the sport better
it actually does
it's just more technique you're not
dealing with like fights aren't stopped
as often with cuts
you know you start letting people cut
like watch what happens when somebody
hits you with an elbow your whole face
opens up they do it right
that's why they call my my [ __ ]
elbows are definitely legal in all mixed
martial arts but in boxing it's uh
yeah but but also you remember to get
the casual fan base you can't bear not
listen ufc just got hip to the casuals
if it was bare knuckle
it's too barbaric
yeah
trust me i think viewership would fall
that's what i'm saying yeah like if
you're trying to be a mainstream sport
it feels um if you're allowed headbutts
if you feel out headbutts and bare
knuckle people i don't want to see this
especially you know just the way society
is not my thing but if you allowed you
know women to you know bear not like
already
so they bare knuckles and they're like
you know
forget head butting i mean you're
kidding me
i mean you soccer kicks to the face when
you're alone yeah you still out yeah
they couldn't do it what else yet jen
currents
here we go
so after facebook went back up uh
mark zuckerberg actually dropped eight
billion on his network saw that and it
says that he is set to keep on a steady
decline because of what's app instagram
and facebook being down for six hours
damn it sounds like facebook it's very
strange like i'm not conspiracy guys
it's weird there's that whistleblower
and then the site the next day goes down
like oh it was on us nobody did it and
you're like what are you erasing in
there what date are you getting rid of i
i think the the really interesting thing
is that they've known for a long time
that their product
is not good for children like and it
just isn't for example when she was
testifying she was like our algorithm
can show you that when you start
googling
healthy recipes as a as a young girl
yeah it leads you very quickly into
anorexia promoting behavior it's so
difficult so
literally and they knew this and it goes
on and on so the rohingya in burma they
are a minority in burma they were the
the military junta or the you know the
power structure was hijacking facebook
pages to spread
false stories
that caused mobs of people to go kill
rohingya so that genocide is being
blamed on how they are manipulating the
facebook algorithm to spread false
information the military is now facebook
goes what are we supposed to do it was a
major problem so it was really
interesting that facebook it said think
about this yeah just like with um
tobacco companies
you're a human being
you get a great job you're working for
i don't know philip morris yep you got a
great house you got your kids are going
to school you have a swimming pool you
got a great community and you look
around and as the evidence starts
mounting you realize [ __ ] my product
kills people but then you do this you go
i'm just supplying a demand
you can do that for just so long until
your kids start coming home going hey
dad
this [ __ ] is killing people mm-hmm and
you know it and i i it's very
interesting what's going on facebook
because i wonder what's going to happen
within the ranks you go i'm making
millions of dollars but the [ __ ]
instagram tick-tock all this stuff is
not good for my own children it's not
good for me it's not good for anybody
we know with mental health like it's so
unhealthy for everybody adults to
children like it's so toxic at what
point did it take some responsibility go
this isn't good it's dividing people
we're spreading misinformation a lot of
myths here's my question how do you take
responsibility because we know that
foreign nationals
china russia israel whoever it might be
are hijacking these platforms and and
creating dissension in america that's
what they want that's what they want
like uh rogan had that mike baker on the
cia and he and they played an interview
from a russian he was kgb and this was
their plan like they they want to pit us
against each other the woke movement the
cancel like they want all this device so
they just push all this like twitter
this is their plan yeah a lot of it is
russian intelligence yeah pushing the
narrative yeah he's like you know people
think it's like james bond like we're
spies he's like that's like 10 of what
we do he's like because he was a
whistleblower he's like what what they
do now their focus is all social media
of course because they can go and divide
someone whoever you can create
wars
chaos you can just spread a story about
how the rohingya are enslaving yeah my
thing is if you're mark zuckerberg and
you're worth who i mean 50 100 million
billion dollars
at what point you go man this is not
good you don't need any more money
you're all set bubba you're good at what
point do you take some and go shut it
down yeah you go man we could something
else gonna pop up but i think him as a
american he's go man we created this
thing this is not what i intend for it
to do it's gotten way out of hand now
that i've seen the analytics i see how
you know it's crushing young people and
spreading misinformation i'm gonna shut
it down here's the problems you got see
how many people work for facebook i was
gonna say that same thing too so you're
responsible for so many people's
employment yeah and you're making a good
point i think no i'm gonna [ __ ] on that
point there so
so let's say they have say they have a
thousand they don't save a thousand
employees okay
we have a thousand employees
sixty thousand sixty thousand not only
do you have 60 000 but you also there's
a lot of good that it does too right so
people it brings people together creates
communities it helps organize for good
causes that's the other that's if that's
the flip side of it what i think you
might see
is
more regulation if you're under 18 you
don't get to be on facebook i mean you
don't get to be on tick tock you don't
have to be on instagram good luck that's
unrealistic it's unrealistic yeah
you have to shut it down i have a 13
year old i i am not opposed to saying to
my 13 year old you're never allowed on
social media i don't think it's good for
you it's just not realistic you know
it's shooting these
friends are on it yeah how do you stop
porn how do you stop these kids who are
10 years old
watching porn and it gets into their
brain they'll find a way
of course
it is it is the problem i don't know
what it is it's our problem it is our it
is our generation's problem quick
question i'm just trying to understand
it a little bit more so what is that
like when he said he lost
all that money like how did how did
somebody work 128 billion dollars so by
getting shut down with advertising all
this stuff guys losing eight billion
dollars okay wow stock people probably
were like oh man they're not that stable
so they're just like pulling out yep
selling stocks yeah advertising
okay it's pretty interesting
i don't know man i mean just watch my
[ __ ] instagram that's all you got to
do guys and that's where you're going
it's interesting that they uh
it's just interesting the hold they have
on society like these it's a monopoly
for sure it's a monopoly
there are five companies that control
all the information the [ __ ] are we
doing
i i don't know
i don't know it's dangerous i got gotta
pee so badly go for it let's do it break
it see you know my face looks leathery
it is i got a tough face i have scar
tissue
i look like i've been on the front of us
a ship and at the sea
and i don't know what to do man i've
tried creams they don't work for me i've
done it all and also i go online it's
tough to navigate the industry finding
the right product for my face what
what are you gonna do man what are you
gonna do what about your skin are you
looking to improve that's why i asked
myself every day do you want to
eliminate those bags under your eyes yes
please is your skin too dry
yes sir
does your partner want you to make some
changes maybe your dude or your gals
like man your face is rough you got to
do some
disco got you covered disco is a clean
skincare brand based in austin texas
all disco products are created
specifically for male skin issues like
under your eye bags dark circles acne
razor burns oily skin dry skin and
wrinkles
disco products are easy to use effective
and affordable they take the guesswork
out of taking care of your skin if
you're going to start a skincare routine
for the first time disco starter set is
a no-brainer the star set is incredibly
simple and convenient way to upgrade
your appearance of your skin in three
simple steps for just 60 seconds a day
you got 60 seconds to look better cool
man we got you covered if you want to
check out disco and try their incredible
skin care products for yourself
the final kid army we got something for
you go to letsdisco.com
fighter enter the code fighter at
checkout for 30 off your first order
that's
letsdisco.com fighter or enter fighter
at checkout for 30 off your first order
i mean we can all agree everyone should
be able to afford their medications
check out good rx they help me find the
lowest price on my prescriptions all the
time with goodrx you can instantly
compare prices for your prescription at
every pharmacy in your hood save up to
eighty percent that's eight zero percent
eighty percent good rx is free and easy
to use and many times cheaper than use
your insurance copay or medicare with
good rx you can find discounts for your
prescriptions at over 70 000 pharmacies
cvs kroger walgreens ride and so much
more good rx is the number one most
downloaded medical app all right
start saving up to 80 on your
prescriptions today go to goodrx.com
fighter that's goodrx.com fighter
goodrx.com fighter good rx is not
insurance but can be used instead of
insurance in 2020 grx users receive an
average savings of 70 off retail prices
again goodrx.com fighter just like every
episode that you've ever heard for the
past nine years fighting the kid is
brought to you by on its supplements
what do you need man what do you need to
achieve your goals you need some help
and you need to trust the supplement
coming you're working with and that's
why we only pitch on it on firing the
kid on it.com has been a loyal supporter
of firing the kid in the whole army of
us with their alpha brain their new mood
their total gut health we got nutrition
for you man we got coffee i love their
coffee they got warrior bars when you're
on the go they got whey protein
plant-based proteins protein bars
protein bites fitness gear streaming
fitness on-demand fitness kettlebells we
have on it sandbags battle ropes they
have it all man there's no reason to
wait till january 1st new year new me
don't wait start right now let ana help
you out with the best supplements best
workout gear on it dot com slash fighter
for 10 off everything
when when i was down i felt like we were
on vacation though it felt great i
actually liked it
hey man
i know he didn't stop you can't stop you
can't stop that unity no come on
yeah so chappelle can't go with me to
vegas this weekend he's in tampa i am i
see stevie blue eyes only is here and i
go uh he was yeah i'm trying to get up
oh yeah man well i can give you some
time in vegas you want to go there he
goes cool that sounds good
he texted me yesterday he goes dude
having trouble finding a dog sitter or
find a hotel take the dog can't go
you know i didn't reply back i stevie i
didn't you i went oh get it together you
know i went oh you're the dog guy now
you're the dog guy now that you can't
you should do things put it down no i
can't you can't say that
of course i'm gonna say that about
butter but i mean it would make me so
angry can you imagine my agent was like
hey dude we uh booked you a gig in
san francisco and ah man let me try and
find a dog
let me try and find a dog sitter baby
leave the dog with you
uh-huh you can it's up to him can the
dog not
wait are you going
uh i was gonna go he was trying to find
a
hotel that would be dog friendly but
last minute it was just so expensive
oh
would have cost it a lot
would have been a pretty penny
leave the dog with your girl and go do
stand-ups stevie you're getting that
random shops giving you a an opportunity
sold out shows yeah to to perform
so that shows i went like this
you butter what's that dog's name
[ __ ] butters you know what i did you
know i can't i knew this would fire up
you know i didn't be you know i did i
went check please
on stevie's career i went check please
check please we'll take the check now
hey bro you know what
look up the word dilite because you just
kind of skating around the edges
butters shuck please
please also you got somebody to take
care of
butters
and you know what all you have to do to
take care of butters
pat em yeah let him sit around heaven he
sleeps a lot
now if you guys had a kid or a child
that makes sense brand new baby
human
sure but a wiener dog sure
it's always going to be like this
evening
stevie's best friend now it is it's uh
his whole
life started when that dog pays his
bills i was gonna say i hope that dog
session only fans of some [ __ ]
he really just wants to stay home and
buy buying fts he wants to be a crypto
dad now a crypto guy hey listen
yeah he's trading out of teas right now
have you seen like my buddy bought an
ape i made fun of him he bought a what
he bought an ape and i know nft nft8
okay he didn't buy a live ape yeah nfta
i was with him in france he's a great
guy smarter he's in the crypto young guy
and i go um and he paid
six grand and i remember looking at him
going i was like you know how you judge
people i went
cool if you don't know like cool you
paid for a digital trading yeah i kind
of got him to he was looking to say if i
go what is this and he was like
reluctant but he started explaining me
nfts well
well that that ape he sold it for what
well no the ape is now worth about 200
grand yeah are you serious
how does that happen and then there is
then there are the cryptos cryptos now
are worth uh
seventy thousand dollars these nfts are
being traded in their own ecosystem it's
getting a little dicey though because
china i think is banning all crypto
because the that cryptocurrency they
can't control it and a lot of banks
don't take it well now with blockchain
though they can you can trace it yeah
yeah it's kind of so so crypto is here
it's the future
yeah yeah but you when i like he's he's
very into this it's like when you want
to facetime with that cryptic i went
check please
yeah and here's another
so now my barber pitched me on now with
the apes now with the apes
with these nfts now they have a serum
that turns it into a
mega ape or something it's a serum
uh they made in eight minutes they made
900 million dollars the people that
created it eight minutes they make 900
million but i like it for the story
about 900 million 900 million dollars
yeah in ethereum i mean
oh got it yeah but i i mean i it i agree
with you it's like
what does that mean but but you got to
get hip to it you know if you want to
you know yeah
yeah i think crazy barbara pitched me on
crypto huh
i have a team who has it when i'm ready
to do it it's just
yeah i can't right now i'm not educated
enough to get involved in it yeah
i'm not that stupid there are ecosystems
where
everybody agrees on a particular
currency or everybody agrees on the
value of something
and that's a community that agrees on it
so sometimes they have you have these
really small niche marketplaces that
deal with only one specific financial
instrument yeah within that they create
these but a lot of it is just like we're
all going to agree that these apes are
worth a lot of money
and you can make a market value
if you do it yeah then all of a sudden
snoop doggy dog gets in on it people get
in on it i don't say doggy
he took away doggy dog
wouldn't let him have it you were doing
honestly
you were doing all right that snoop
doggy
doggy
dog
snoop dogg doggy dog dog is well it's
like i tried buying a winston churchill
painting because i'm i'm really into the
crown and i went you know what's a good
investment a win still a winston
churchill painting well sir
hey dum-dum that was forever ago and you
think you're the first one to buy a
winston churchill painting who's a
really good painter
and uh i think the lowest one i found
was a million bucks oh and then uh anna
uh angelina jolie bought one sold it for
11 million dollars yeah check please
yeah yeah yeah yeah getting into crypto
joe was like that's a good idea i'm like
right let me look
[Music]
what they don't tell you is how many
people lose money on crypto and how many
people lose
yeah because yeah it all sounds good you
guys don't know it's not like anything
else really know that they know it know
it yeah and they live it like this guy
that i know has made money on the ape he
lives it 24 7. it's a very different
kind of thing that's it's like my dove
davidoff dove makes a lot of money in
real estate but dove's been doing real
estate
for 25 years like and he's so deep in it
with really good guys well that's when
he got buddies you're like dude let me
get in real estate are you yeah how many
people lose their their ass in real
estate
or restaurants yeah most do you don't
hear about any of that but that's the
majority of people that's exactly what
my dad said to me i go i'm gonna get
into real estate
my father goes cool you guys what are
you gonna do and i was like i gotta ask
this guy and he goes he goes what do you
what do you know about uh real estate
it's a really casual question
cause he's seen so many people it's good
to talk to older heads about it my dad's
the same way
my dad's the one who got me to start the
network because i met with two different
people who own networks and they want to
give me equity in their company and
bring all my shows over there and i was
talking my dad about i'm like they're
going to give me you know 20 of this and
it's evaluated at 30 million
and they both offer you this are you
going to use that and have so how much
money let's say you did it and then sold
it the next day how much you're going to
get that that's that's like 7 million
bucks you think
now do you think
in some weird world they're offering you
that for a reason i go i mean probably
because i do the heels and now do you
think that you couldn't do it yourself
and bet on yourself and do it down the
road i go
here because it sounds like you have all
the things in place but you just want to
take the easy route out i'm like oh
you're right dad yeah that's when thick
boys started that's what's what dads are
around yeah yeah they've been your dad
smart guy yeah monster yeah monster
and you need that you do and you're
lucky to have that too sometimes just to
have super like an older head to bounce
[ __ ] off a lot of guys don't have that
nine super fortunate and that's where
you see super busy they start going
headlong into something and you're like
there are certain things here that
you're you're not taking into account
people who make a lot of money in most
you get lucky sometimes but for the most
part the people i know have made a lot
of money in business know that business
they spend a lot of time in that
business and the devils
the the details will kill you the devil
is in the details it's the details you
don't [ __ ] pay attention to yeah it
was like this guy is your [ __ ] yeah
they lose your ass this these these uh
this dude uh in alaska had a hotel he
started hotel we've stayed at it and he
goes dude because there are things i was
losing my ass on plastic keys
yeah people would throw them away and i
had to keep replenishing it was just oh
[ __ ] it's little details like you're
like a [ __ ]
what else you got jen
so dave chappelle released his latest
netflix comedy special la yesterday i
believe you were seen in here yeah i've
seen it yesterday you guys like it yeah
he's a monster monster it felt more like
a ted talk in my opinion though he's
gotten more that way a little bit but
there's definitely some great points
yeah absolutely like the point you're
about to bring up with the babies
hilarious yeah yeah so uh there are two
things that really went viral shortly
after the special dropped one is that he
had a joke about uh the baby and how
people care more about him offending the
lgbt community than they do about him
killing someone walmart his point was he
goes he goes this is how crazy things
are he goes the baby who you know top
songs on the chart
before those top songs and this is true
and he goes you can google it he goes
murdered a man
shot him in walmart at point blank range
and walmart most people don't know that
but he was trying to get right yeah he
would defend himself
so they dropped there's no charges
against them he was but he killed
another black man no he talks about that
he goes but if you if if you hurt the
feelings of a gay person you better
watch out
yeah that's very true it's so funny and
then i think he said i don't know his
joke but he i think he goes uh how about
i trade you i won't do any uh lgbqt
jokes anymore if you uh release the baby
yeah that's what he said
well he did he probably the guy was
probably trying to [ __ ] rob him they
saw the video and he you know
i don't know what happened
it's very well known
like it's very well it's very well known
it's very kill together yeah that's a
great well very well known like not too
many people actually know it i'm saying
if you're if you're
if you know the baby you listen to him i
love the baby yeah yeah i'm a super fan
yeah yeah so i knew that
anybody talks about his songs yeah yeah
uh what is it the cop car song he talks
about shooting in front of his to defend
his two-year-old daughter yeah he's like
yeah because he was with his daughter
he's like he's like
yeah he's like i'll do it oh yeah right
there damn holy [ __ ] they're just going
to show the i know body like that why
did i do that wait walmart the guy came
at him with a gun came out and won a gun
was already shot and killed by the
rising uh during a fight that broke out
in the in the fight
first do you imagine dying in a walmart
[ __ ] dude you died in walmart on that
walmart floor
you know that's the key they had to keep
things moving well it's like you see
that uh on cnn or whatever news station
watch i'm sure you saw uh this morning
it said uh uh you know um
mass shooting mass shooting there's a
active shooter in arlington texas at a
high school there well the more facts
because obviously that's what gets
clicks and that's you know that's what
you will be oh my god another mass
shooter crazy white guy well no it was a
black guy who got in a fight and started
shooting at the guys who were fighting
him he was not an actor he wasn't trying
to show he was everybody in the fight
yeah yeah
yeah you see that there was this i saw
these dudes who just started shooting at
each other in a mall a crowded mall just
like pulling out guns and you're like
you know you're on camera you know your
life's done now
do you see what happens no you see what
happened in chicago
there's video just i mean at a house
it's just semi-automatics
they have camera they have everything
the cop they we know who they are cops
apprehended them they posted bail
there's no charges pressed nothing and
the community's like what in the [ __ ]
you can just open fire on a house and
there's no repercussions
there's nothing right they won't press
charges although the cops can press
charges yeah dude yeah
it's that woke mare out there oh lori
lightfoot well when i was out there
there people were like don't go to
chicago right now because [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] happens and nobody and it's not
just on the south side anymore it's it's
taking over downtown exactly right and i
love chicago i love chicago one of my
favorites where where is not the winners
yeah video there's there's the guys just
started blo
you're like holy [ __ ] dude what the [ __ ]
really just chicago house [ __ ] typing
guy star blast in chicago chicago
shooting
house
i said 2021
uh just go chicago go back
there goes 21.
real quick you know more kids have died
from gunfire than cobot yeah and carry
on yes this is it right here
um months ago that's three months ago
this is super recent was that night
right nope it's middle middle of the day
middle of the day i saw a video middle
of the day
i don't know
no because they let them go someone was
killed but that that see uh that might
be it this is six hours yeah that makes
sense there you go
that guy's suited
to the shooting
nobody else noticed that his suit
doesn't fit
the offenders he's got weird shoulders
in austin that left one dead and two
others injured one friday still the
source of simmering
between the mayor and state's attorney
we have to understand how it's possible
when this kind of shootout is captured
on film that there were no charges of
any person even though
people were brought into custody
this is not a time for scapegoating
she's a beast
she's also the girl that for political
rhetoric jesse smallett he's calling out
the major defenders
i'm hard-pressed to think about what the
additional evidence would be when it's
all on capturing videotape you got
officers on the scene who have body cam
and dash cam
what more is necessary there's a
shootout in austin
our number one concern should be about
getting those people prosecuted
not a headline diverting attention away
from the fact that we have not had a
comprehensive plan for violence in the
city of chicago fox said if detectives
gather additional evidence the case
could be revisited potentially leading
to charges potentially revisiting the
attorney's office is here ready to hold
those
who cause harm to our communities
accountable for their actions whatever
the other evidence is that needs to be
gathered the police department is going
to be johnny on the spot and make sure
we get it but this is a she expresses a
very compelling case kim fox is calling
for a meeting with the mayor the police
superintendent what's the problem is
area 5
they're just not doing anything
those guys just on the third they're
so you know chicago the crime's so bad
out there that cops won't even go into
the neighborhoods so you know she wanted
to defund the police and do all the [ __ ]
and then when the riots started she
hired security with guns
what a surprise yeah glorious
she looks so she's uh she'll be out i
don't think people are very happy with
her no how could you be
what else you got you what yes
hbo has officially dropped the trailer
the main guy well not the main guy he's
one of the main guys in the
crown too
he
my friend pat divinity looks identical
to that man that's all i can see
house of the vinnie
d-e-v-e-e-n-y i think i think it was
this one let me double check here no no
that's not it d e what d e
v
other quarterback delvin no no no no he
didn't play quarterback
d-e-v-e-e-n-y see if that pops up and
why
there it is
obituary no he didn't die
if he did i just saw him over the
weekend that'd be terrible
if you do type in cu football
is it this guy here
no how dare you do what that guy kind of
looks like that's not my friend
i look like him
she clicks the guy the bottom right has
nuts hanging up his neck
this your friend right here
figure it out
chin
oh it's over now listen we can't find it
he looks identical to him just know he
looks identical to the [ __ ] guy the
prequel to this guy and but it's not
from the writers who wrote the original
one who is that guy who's that actor
different writers but no he's not new
he's in the crowd
he's the yeah
he's the husband of uh queen elizabeth
ii in the crown god he was a
real [ __ ] in that
he's a piece of [ __ ] i'm sorry it's hard
for me to talk about any other tv show
besides squid game joe brian i'm four of
them
oh my god uh i just finished four
hey bro
wait until you get to six oh my god
six is
unbelievable i'm loving
how many episodes is that brian
brian you're so right the acting the
storyline the way they set everything up
written and directed by one perfect
written directed by one person there was
a story that came out about the creator
of squid games where uh he wrote it in
2000 the early 2000's and every single
studio passed on it until 12 years later
he actually had to stop writing squid
games in order to sell his laptop
because he was so broke oh i love him
yeah a great story had this script for a
while i love it well and then what let's
wait five years for brennan to watch it
i know i know but not you know you know
i i would watch it if you guys didn't
like it so much it drives me nuts
and then you'll be in the hips no and
this is this is for you this is for you
and really you if i hear one more time
hey no listen to me listen to me i'm
never going to watch it hey i'm never
going to watch it if i hear this figure
this is especially for you if i hear it
one more time the way it's shot in the
acting oh my god it's [ __ ] incredible
unless you're quentin tarantino
i don't want to hear it you got it i
don't hear about the acting i've never
watched a major netflix show on or hbo
or on show time yet man that's some
terrible act they're all good they're
all good
everybody's good
they're professional actors
i hear it one more time no but here's
the thing
one more time i'm gonna fight you listen
man i'm gonna [ __ ] you up i'll fight you
over squid game cool dude what if i hear
one more thing about the way it shot
shut up i'm gonna piss down your throat
shut up that's aggressive dude
[ __ ] strong as [ __ ] lately let him
know brian i'm tight i haven't even
eaten today and i feel so [ __ ]
energized bro hey let's do this once we
rap because you feel so good yeah let's
wrestle whoever taps the other one out
has to shout out the other ones dates
do you want to play that or no
come on squid game
come on squid boy it's been a little
tough on me lately why because you're a
little better
[ __ ]
can i use certain techniques whatever
you want i'll even let you start with
whatever you want okay i kind of you
start on my back if you want you want
you want me to help you use bashful
eagle claw
sure all right let's do it squid boy
okay
hey that's for everyone here one more
time how that thing's well shot and i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna just one more
thing one more wet
cold dick there's one more thing shot
amazingly yep no there's one more thing
one more thing
it's that girl's first time acting ever
and she kills it
she actually broke a record on instagram
she's the most followed person within a
three-week span 15 million i think uh
14. it's amazing it's amazing i know
it's a squid game
two words for you
squid game let me see the trailer for
the new game of thrones i don't like
that the original guys didn't write it
though
really a lot of people don't like that
uh
that's the other thing if i hear again
those guys ruined season 8 shut up
[Laughter]
shut up
season 8 was fantastic
i know it came to an end usain [ __ ]
cried over the sopranos shut up app do
it yourself but write it yourself but
write it yourself all right let's see
there's dragons yeah yeah bunch of
dragons [ __ ] yeah oh this is brian's
world man
i'm in
i'll show you some of the same actors
but you really can't 200 years before
yes
i'm so hard right now
i'm into the dragon starring the man
dragon himself
someone needs to redo that and then and
then have your face in there yep yep
just start
starting
dragging
dude i would love to do that and no
scales just me yeah they can imagine
the dragon
it's just a it's a naked man
and then flames coming out of your mouth
no you have to have a tail though
you got to have you got to have the
flames coming up you gotta
yeah it'd be sick flying like this yeah
cause how do you fly seven million views
cat are you into it oh i'm into it yeah
man yeah everyone's gonna be into it
even if it is different is there any
good is there any good uh scary [ __ ]
popping right now oh the same creators
of uh haunting of hill house came out
with midnight mass how is it i've
watched one episode so far it's good
it's a series it's the same kind of vibe
like creepy eerie kind of scary there's
a build up to it oh you know how i got
really into uh
love on the spectrum
with the the season twos out which is
great uh they do find love in that but
uh there's a new series my english
friends were talking about it's from uh
i think 2012.
it's called uh undateable not the
crystalia show with whitney cummings
it's the uk version but it's it was
before love on the spectrum
huh go no uh yeah the undateables oh oh
wow uh no click on the far left one
that's
the guy on the far right i'm like i'm in
i'm [ __ ] watch it or how about the
gums on becky on the left i'm [ __ ] in
those gums
i'm in on all it goes on becky
whose teeth would you rather have brian
yours are the practices
i got the black guys
can you fix that well it's called
undateable for a reason how about chris
how about crazy eyes look at the crazy
car this guy that guy
i'm in
i'm [ __ ] in that's real
you can watch on amazon is that oh
that's homie's wife yep i can't
yeah that's tough
i'll watch it oh too fantastic when
these people find love there's nothing
happier dude yeah it's all they want and
they're in off the bat as long as
somebody's into kind of what they're
into like that guy who's balls deep in
dinosaurs she was like i kind of like
dinosaurs he's like do you want to get
married right now and there was they
knew each other for three minutes dale
yeah well this there it is uh i need to
see the girl with the gums i don't know
why i'm a little obsessed with it i
don't know why what
yeah it's interesting huh i see more
pictures up what's her name
i can't just type in the girl with the
gums right girl the girls i feel bad but
undateable uk girl
no cast there you go
yeah but they're telling me that it's
better than love on the spectrum
really and clearly obviously i don't
want you to make fun of them i watch it
because you are interested they're just
yeah and like they want love so bad i
can't watch it it makes me sad no no
that's what i'm saying that's how i got
stuff because they find a lot of them
find love no it's people it's not like
that it's it's not making fun of them
it actually makes you understand them
more this is your squid games for them
yes
yeah you gotta watch squid games oh look
at that happy couple yeah look at them
okay good for you christine ray and
christine just fix your teeth you don't
want to his teeth are fine yeah no let
them have it
where'd she go
then i'm sure we'll find him he goes
there she is yes emily
emily and mitchell
yeah that's just something going on is
there a way to fix her gums
there's a way to fix that
could you put in veneers
when there's a way to fix [ __ ]
what maybe she doesn't care it doesn't
look that bad it doesn't look good when
she smiles like really big then it
i think yeah her lips are a lot together
her lips just rises but there's some
people not on the spectrum with those
same gums what are we talking about here
yeah all right well dude this is where
it's kind of tough man i'm i i know but
we have to say that i'm going to get sad
now yeah so let's not her
no she found love yeah
that's so cool all i know is i'm [ __ ]
in they told me you've never seen on
tables you can like no because i'm not
from the uk they went it's better than
love on the spectrum i said say less i
think when you have kids you get so sad
for their parents no dude i'm telling
you it's not these shows aren't like
that it makes you understand what they
go through and they're super like loving
and yeah some have like a superpower
it's fantastic
all you want is your kids to be happy
and not lonely you have your kids on the
spectrum yeah you probably might feel
certain well there's nothing i think if
to watch your child be lonely and not be
able to make friends would be the
hardest thing that's that
your heart would be broken yeah my
second youngest brother is
yeah autistic oh yeah
how artistic he's pretty he's up there
yeah yeah yeah so he's gonna need his
mom he's with my yeah he's with my mom
and does he have any super power uh is
he like really good at counting or is he
in the dinosaurs remembers dates of like
certain events like a [ __ ] and
then uh he can fix
like anything electrical really quick
yeah [ __ ] yeah it's like insane
it's just like
they excel in that stuff like that that
guy on loving the spectrum he meets uh
he's dating this girl needs the family
first time he goes in whatever
1942 do you know what today is famous
for no no and he knows like the titanic
where it went down how it went down like
he knows all like dates like yeah
history knows all history
so it's kind of cool yeah it's kind of
cool yeah
all right but he's looking for a wife
what else you got jen all right um happy
news
i saw this
oh yes
yes he says he's cancer-free he had
stage four lymphoma holy [ __ ] yeah
they can cure
the lead singer uh well they switch back
they they have back which one's uh mark
so mark's the guy on the far right
yeah and then tom's in the middle and
then now tom's the guy who's balls deep
in aliens yes he's the one that he's a
big real big in the aliens he's not with
them anymore though right tom uh no but
i think there is talks with them the
original yeah apparently
they've made a lot of progress with
lymphoma man yeah you can you can
actually
if with the right treatments you can
actually that's awesome right yeah yeah
he's a stud i love that guy
that's his hair he made his hair gray
and everything and all right brian what
is your hair
[Laughter]
that is your haircut take that back he
starts rubbing his head
i have an appropriation here i gotta get
back on my [ __ ] propecia why'd you
get up what is that once you go to four
hours
i got lazy i gotta get more i gotta go
get a checkup i haven't done any of that
[ __ ] yeah yeah jacob feel [ __ ] strong
and [ __ ] all that matters man oh how
about surprise you got off uh rogaine
mark harley on uh his podcast is talking
about whether i'm natty or not and i
love that there's a debate oh no on the
new one it drops thursday oh i love that
people are actually natalie you're not
wondering that or not last week was you
right it was me yeah
i mean i look pretty mad
so do i
you'll know when i'm doing something
you'll know that's gonna be fantastic
yeah you'll know will you know will i
get more muscular if i get on you always
look the same yeah i don't think this
will make you look different it'll it
will it
so yeah it will make a difference if i
lift if i do stuff i think no matter
what i think you you're going to look
different
i can't wait are you going to start
doing stuff yeah i don't feel like
needed now yeah i feel strong enough do
what you do but i wanted to figure out
what i wanted to suck your face
when you're 60 if you get on it i wonder
if that's safe
i think it is but i think if you're
losing here it's going to speed that up
you bald is hilarious well i could shave
my head but i'm not going to look at
that i mean i could shave it tight no no
you have a good shaped head i have a
good shaped head no it's long but the
thing is
hold on what
is a long leg
because then it's going to be like the
old man like you're gonna look like
captain kirk i'll look real tight to the
bone yeah we gotta go bald like rogan or
dana we
i feel strong there you go you keep
saying that's what i said after this we
can wrestle mate well let's do something
because we know how the wrestling's
gonna go although i've never really
wrestled you
i've never really done my [ __ ] because i
lay here's what you do let me pop his
head down i'm gonna ruin this thing you
have one move you know that right yep
that you can't stop
well
uh we've never actually gone at it on a
mat for real we don't need to no listen
we can do it in here we've never
actually don't [ __ ] up this is car
[ __ ] up the lights like chin did well
we can do it out there the problem is i
don't like being on a rug i know we
should get mats we should definitely get
masks for like a section of this yes and
i have to be careful my next but having
said that maybe we see something where i
squeeze you and you squeeze me
what
do you mean
well you know how shane shane uh carwin
squeezed me until i gave up yep i want
to see if i squeeze you and then you try
to squeeze me we see who the [ __ ] can
win okay it's gonna be an even playing
field otherwise we started death
otherwise we get into this [ __ ] and then
we and then i and then i end up arm
dragging you and then you're like oh
it's not fair you know what's the bummer
at the end of the day you're still
losing your hair and that's what this
whole conversation is about and i want
you to shave it bald
ball daddy no bake it no yeah
no yeah
it'll be a sponsor for manscape it'd be
like a big deal just shave them at some
point if you yeah if you did that i mean
you still got a good shaped head that's
something don't listen to him at some
point though you're gonna come in here
yeah
he's gonna be gone no you guarantee it
dude
i'll get i'll go to turkey and get a
hair transplant well you don't want to
tell me that
oh no i want you to talk to me his
friends went to turkey and got great
hair transplants why where in l.a dude
turkeys
turkeys
turkeys like colombia for ass yeah it's
like thirteen hundred dollars versus
thirteen thousand it's a good deal but
then again you're flying there yeah and
you got then you get doing the you're in
the hospital for how long you can be fun
to go no you're in the hospital it's the
same day procedure i did it did they put
you under no i did it i you watched two
movies and you're done i did it in i did
it 15 years ago what did they do who is
the doctor uh richard bernstein well
they take the ball as a cucumber let's
not go to him no well so what are you
doing no it's my hair so they take a
strip out now they do it like piece by
piece they take a strip out under a
microphone they take it out and they
they dig holes they seat it it's like
irrigation for your head that's what
theo did right it's [ __ ] does it oh
it's painful for no reason he does kind
of transplant yeah he he likes he
doesn't need a hair transplant he's got
he got his hair's down to here do you
know why you know i did it my dad said
oh if you do it i'll do it i'll pay for
it you paid six grand
and i was like all right and then he
never did it he was like
well probably because yours yours didn't
take music i'm all set they're all
scabbed up i had to wear a hat it was so
it hurt last time this was probably 15
years ago when i got a hair transplant i
figured you and rogan did it together
and get two friends
he went another knife twice or three
times just didn't take him i don't know
why you guys don't wear wigs yeah just
let your hair go get a little ball
everyone has one i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah yeah i made fun of plastic surgery
meanwhile i had my [ __ ] lids down
you've got more plastic than anybody i
know i'm i've had more plastic surgery
everybody anybody know anything you want
to hear guys don't be a dick dude
i i don't know anybody else that has
more than okay i had my lips yeah you're
against it i had my lipstick and your
hair twice all right once not twice i
had it once once i swear to god i'll
have it done again if i have to but i
don't know i bet you that doctor like
did brian kimberly's like
no
no no he keeps using the name but yeah
look at that 1800 bucks you go to mexico
nope click on it chin let me see what
kind of before which one the hair uh
turkey uh no go to mexico that's gonna
be easier on brian these are ads by the
way
no it's good [ __ ]
dude
but look it's a turkish clinic in mexico
by the way i know i know a couple of
dudes um who are rather famous who got
it and they're so quiet about it and i
was like you're a [ __ ] loser just
tell people yeah who cares shut up so
the procedure will be formed by a
turkish medical team dude two nights at
a channel
two nights breakfast you're in and out
with breakfast yeah with breakfast you
see that you know i like that they have
on their antibiotics
that's good that they at least let you
know yep
operation care shampoo
in the surgery day whoa personal
translator okay but you get to go to to
turkey no no this is mexico by turkish
cancun yeah they're all from turkey
so you don't have to go all the way to
turkey dude yeah i don't know that ain't
that long of a flight i'll go to [ __ ]
i'll go to beverly beverly hills for
that i'm not going to turkey i don't
care about that i mean but man look at
that guy it could be you that guy that
could be you
they don't show how they did it he's
already got here wait so what happens
when they do like a haircut does it just
grow back that same way
some people have great hair so if you
have the kind of hair i don't have good
hair and i have a tight scalp got it if
you have that thick hair in the back
it'll look really good you can put i
don't think he look at his [ __ ] hair
it looks terrible in the before yeah he
is that he's a dime piece now dude
i like how they uh block out his eyes
like oh we can't tell who that is yeah
right now it's like we'll just go look
for that magnet
all right ready god that guy looks good
um
[Music]
uh this was just going viral bill
beldrick's son
is he on spectrum
i don't know but it looks like
because he kept going yeah so there's
one of them here we got him i think he's
on the spectrum
they just put him on the team to like
get footballs
and then he goes what's his title
right these are those tom brady moments
and we might as well have [ __ ] theo
on the sidelines
look at this guy is he really is he
really on the spectrum no no he just has
like you know facebook oh he's not he's
got some ticks yeah some facial tics
he's definitely he's just really into
that doesn't seem like the most loving
guy either
uh
his dad seems pretty intense
is he on the team with his dad that's it
yeah he's a coach okay i don't know what
his exact title is but
he's part of the personnel there all
right this white sox fan was able to
catch a ball with her prosthetic leg
[ __ ] sick fantastic
i think i had the tick tock here
five beers deep and taking my leg off
oops sorry
oh and she caught the ball she got the
ball with her leg oh they don't show the
actual throat they do it's just i gotta
rewind this thing
this one i didn't get to read about yet
but i think she's saying something like
other white people not that are
non-jewish are playing jewish characters
and she i guess she doesn't like that i
think is she just trying to clicks for
her podcast i don't know what he's
listening to and i like her she's a
[ __ ] beast comic and also very
attractive the thing is though is what's
tough about her saying about like jews
playing juice she's done blackface in
her skits before she's played other [ __ ]
so it's like i think if you're an actor
you should be allowed to play anybody
even i think that's the point of acting
exactly and this whole thing where you
have to be
the actual person is so [ __ ]
ridiculous yes
it'll get you in the headlines though
they're even doing that with like
writers and [ __ ] like
like a black person has to write for a
black person
like
so forth you said the best there's a lot
of anti-semitism out there right now
especially apparently really i don't see
it oh it's become it's become very
acceptable actually to
so so criticism of israel for example
now you have kamala harris
essentially applauding
um
this student who was talking about how
israel was committing genocide against
the palestinians
it was like
it's it's become there there are a lot
of things talking about white privilege
jewish privilege how a lot of the the
the white power structure is actually
jewish money and all this stuff to go to
conspiracy the whole conspiracy
community there's all this the
rothschilds
i think it's easy to go after jewish
people because they're so successful
always has so it's it's easy to
obviously successful people get the most
[ __ ] jews are very used to that that's
always yeah they don't give a [ __ ]
well they give a [ __ ] because what
happens historically is they get killed
with all this that's the conspiracy [ __ ]
that goes on i mean yeah and i haven't
been hanging with sam too long
jews aren't getting killed right now no
no there's there's a tremendous amount
of anti-semitism though and if you look
at the a lot of these there are a lot of
organizations that track this stuff uh
and semitic
activity is way up in some some
descriptions
all right let's do
okay so i've shown jamie foxxer before
right so he posts like he doesn't really
i don't know how much of a current event
this is but he posts these pictures and
doesn't tag anything so i know he has a
glasses company he helps me for that but
he doesn't all the hot girls just like
yes fire daddy
he just does this well he looks pretty
sweet though
multiple selfies in a row
and how about how many likes uh 167
that's my refresher
driving a rolls royce i have some of
those uh sunglasses
yeah but he made him like 967.
yeah i think they're supposed to be
luxury glasses that look yeah you get
whichever they're cheaper
and then this one i thought was weird
too he does he's a book tour going on
but he uses this picture does this look
like him to you uh well there he i think
he's pretty because he's tyson mike
tyson so i'm sure that that picture is
done when he's playing mike time all
right well i'll give him that then so
you brought this up just to hate on him
no i'm just i find it i find it
fascinating that he does this he's like
super famous i think when you get to
that level of fame sometimes you just
don't see what you're doing
including this guy right here
well he's just vin diesel this is what
he posted recently it says follow your
dreams
he's on smith press squat rack i don't
know
think there's also a game that these
people are old they don't really know
how to yeah yeah they're just they don't
have like the social etiquette of social
media but also i i doubt vin diesel runs
his instagram oh he does i almost feel
like he does yeah yeah you think so
what team is gonna post this for me
[Laughter]
it's just so weird but then
but the rock the rock is super famous
this box is better yeah but okay so the
rock is super he should be the craziest
out of everyone but he's like the most
like down to
earth you personally
smith too yeah
yeah he has a team but he has a team
yeah he's a straight up team squad derek
poston used to write for him yeah yeah
all righty
a lot of people are tagging us in this i
guess playboy has now
these new models
i love him okay so he's super famous
right he's super [ __ ] little
this guy
rock he's [ __ ] famous famous
it's amazing yeah he is yeah
like go to his instagram i know it's
like a gazelle bunny brian
look at how many followers 17.8 million
damn he's a bunny he's a little bad
bunny million followers and he's just a
model for playboy now he just does a lot
of instagram content yeah he does videos
right yeah he does videos on what he
went viral because he used to do videos
with his sister when he was in high
school and he it's just like them
bickering and he went viral
oh he copied aaliyah aliyah
but yeah this dude gets views views how
about this person i'm just gonna say it
thank you
all right
uh man there's also another dude is
there any chicks there is where's that
other dude so this is the one that we
tagged in the most
another playboy model
dude and this is uh
a lot of freckles
i think playboy is just in a stage where
they're revamping their content they're
trying to figure something out yeah
they're dying they're trying to stay
woke don't they have a magazine
dedicated to that though like play girl
or something wasn't it uh yeah i don't
know how that's gonna work out they were
already dying people are don't need
magazines dude if i'm playboy i just
double down on bad [ __ ] big thick
[ __ ] but they you just go to the end
the internet kills playboy the magazines
no instagram killed it i mean because i
can go on instagram and find the baddest
girls in the world and just stare adam
jack off yeah
it's tough like why are you gonna who's
gonna buying a playboy magazine nobody
for a spread for a centerfold all right
girl in their tits what are you talking
about dude there's only fans now
that's a pretty dope hoodie
no i guess they're doing i mean it's a
very average hoodie i'll go back to you
you don't know that guy who is he annoys
me no i said you don't know that guy he
said again
what's the girl in the middle chin
please click on a girl for the love of
god
right he's going everywhere else it's
kind of crazy how they can they just do
a little bit of pixelation but it still
looks like a nipple
um
she's a little too skinny for my
attention yeah they're usually right too
there's no skinny teeth aren't they
normally that's more your flavor right
gin that's beautiful that's a nice body
a great ride yeah she's gorgeous chin
likes them skinny but um but play you
guys playboy they're just trying to
figure it out man yeah it's tough these
are thicker who's the playmates playboy
playmate of the year right now
2021 do you have any of i don't think
they can do that anymore
that's why i'm asking even at hooters
you can't hire girls with big jugs
jugs
yeah yeah
yeah i said jugs
you can't do that because they say it's
discrimination yeah right now
they can't discriminate against people
yeah because i had a a friend back in
the day who used to work at hooters and
she was flat-chested so she would wear
like three bras to make it look like she
had big boobs and now now they can't so
they can't yeah it's like a
discrimination if you've got a flat
chest can we get hooters
there you go
wow all right and that's kind of i mean
also i saw this i don't want to
so laurel hubbard was named sportsman of
the year sports woman of the year but it
was for like her alma mater school or
something like that
and uh that she that was the transgender
who competed yeah but she didn't get to
play yeah right
that's embarrassing but that was a
sports woman of the year
for what magazine though though
daily times i think that's from her like
alma mater oh yeah
i get i get
just so overwhelmed with this stuff i'm
just like i don't look at brian just
rubbing his head that's what i feel like
he's just rubbing hands
dude i got i've got dudes who are in
like playboy bunny outfits i think it's
a change under [ __ ] just clicking on
guys you know that's what set me that
was taking all my energy that's what
triggered me stopping you a little bit i
think i gotta chin there's guys on
playboy yeah that guy who was on playboy
was on tiger belly a few like a year or
two
cool the asian dude yeah they usually do
i love this guy
yeah oh this is so dope
justin ran up posted this
and then he has nike socks of adidas
this is this has to be florida yeah yeah
[Music]
alligator's like what in the [ __ ] god
damn
oh my god
jesus christ that was intense
jesus
yeah
i think this last one so dolph lundgren
has a fiancee she's 24 years old he's
63. 64.
oh there they are he's 64. 63 64. he
looks great
great he's amazing yeah he's stuck
yeah he's
he's a beast dude he's really smart yep
how's this girl 24. she's
simply delicious and i think i had met
his
other girlfriend
[Music]
years ago no that's just that might be
the same one a year ago how long has he
been with her that might be the one does
he have kids because i'm sure his kids
are the same age which is strange right
maybe he's 63. yeah it depends
yes
wow
ava ida and greta would see how old ida
is
she's 25 so she's older than his but
yeah yeah but you same [ __ ] yourself
she's pretty too you must be nice
he's a true viking
yeah they're from stockholm
norway west sweden
sweden stockholm is in sweden oh yeah
old guy into young chicks weird all
right columbus i'll see you this weekend
columbus funny bone come see me and then
i got timonium i gotta say columbus
is it md
it does say
ohio i think not missouri wow
wow uh
tomorrow
october 14th
october 22
at brian's 23
let's look at brian's website maybe he
took it from brian's website
nope
no it says ohio on there all right uh
there's not a columbus maryland that i'm
familiar with i made that where is that
from
rico
we got one giant
job
one job not me
it's columbus ohio with brian october
8th through the 9th and then i'm in
vegas this thursday friday saturday and
then next week i know it's not updated
one job uh next friday saturday i'm at
prayer improv break california two shows
friday two shows saturday and then
dallas texas the big one for your boy
dallas texas addison improv give me a
special night i'll keep you posted we'll
get closer but those shows will sell out
that's november 11th through the 13th
addison improv dallas texas but this
weekend is vegas thursday friday
saturday new club wise guys
this weekend i'll be in tampa florida uh
you look like you're telling ghost
stories there i know this picture uh
that's side splitters and then october
28th through the 30th i'll be in
washington dc
at the dc comedy loft november 17th
tacoma uh
comedy club and then november
18th spokane comedy club it's not on
there but december 1st
uh i'll be at uh san jose improv it's a
ways away huh yeah
alrighty boom
all right kids love you that's it see
you soon vegas we out
let's try it
sorry
that's why i do this
you can't you can't hit me here
you don't want to use feet
do you really want to use t-shirts
you cut that oh
[Music]
keep punching everywhere guys
no get on my neck you can't you can't do
next [ __ ]
it's not fair
no
no no you're hitting my dick
no hidden fists
where the
you can't pat my dick like that that's
not cool no no no
no next stop
oh [ __ ]
on my elbow
i need a mat dude
we need mats
all right but don't do all your weird
[ __ ] with your [ __ ] jiu-jitsu that
it wouldn't work in the street
striking
hey
[Music]
that's good that's not a good situation
[Laughter]
he's in my gate
all right
okay
so
i think i got the best of him until he
picked me up
i'm 54.